a mountainous region dotted with quaint
villages where most of the inhabitants
are Catholic and almost all of them are
employed this is CSU heartland in upper
bavaria and it's alexander hot vons
constituency the CSU has put forward a
candidate here for the past 30 years
it's become almost a tradition to vote
for the CSU is in Fort we're here on the
ground and add a weekly market like this
one where there are so many local
farmers and producers contact is
established immediately put on my king
we know each other and that's why
there's a basis of trust with the
residence inn is I'd know the Federal
Minister of Agriculture has made a
special trip here today but people
aren't really taking much notice some of
the organic farmers doubt her promises
of more support but they remain friendly
he'll get more money in the future
that's what everyone wants of course but
I don't believe it it's true it's almost
settled we'll see how it turns out in
the end
such meetings are part and parcel of God
Vaughn's daily life he's been in the CSU
for about three decades he was a member
of the European Parliament for many
years and now he's in the bavarian state
parliament in the fall he hopes to join
the Bundestag
velvet of olive oil I think we need
Europe Europe is a peace project that
brought affluence and especially peace
which don't keep off the finding feet
and if we want to have a voice in Europe
and as Bavarians in the world then we
also need the EU that means we still
focus a critical eye on Europe hi flung
European politics are not on the agenda
at the next meeting it's all about nuts
and bolts a businessman wants to open a
home-improvement store in the village
not on its outskirts is there anything
you can see here that you'll take back
with you to Berlin believe you not
really [ __ ] put economic policy is
always rooted in concrete local issues
if you don't know what's going on
politically and economically at the
local level there's no point in
discussing an abstractly in Berlin
obstructing billion limit on funding at
his next appointment hot one once again
sees how issues in the Bavarian
provinces are affected by global
politics
milk from 600 organic farmers is
processed here at the on duxx dairy for
generations cheese milk and yogurt have
been produced here without chemicals and
certainly without genetic modification
we try to adapt to the market people
worry that quality standards will suffer
because of the proposed free trade
agreement between the EU in the u.s. odd
Vaughn now has to deal with consumer
protection free trade agreements are
important but they shouldn't lead to the
watering down of standards and norms
despite campaigning God Vaughn can't
neglect his work at the state parliament
in Munich he works efficiently and he's
proud that Bavaria's the only German
state that is not in debt still he's
annoyed about the recent scandal in the
state in which dozens of
parliamentarians were accused of
providing their relatives with high
paying jobs it's easily goes as the
biggest faction the CSU was of course
most affected by this there was an
appropriate outcry though and the state
parliament also reacted in my discussion
with citizens today I always make clear
that we're thinking about how to correct
this matter and stop the practice that's
one big kid that's mighty this team I
even puig ending up together
these days God Vaughn who's unmarried
rarely gets a chance to go for a long
walk with his dog clava he loves this
region he was born here after all the
fact that his father came from Egypt and
named him Alexander jama'at Vaughn is
not an issue for him under mother's hype
up their immigration background but in
the CSU here in the constituency of me
Spock it's simply understood and doesn't
need to be talked about
next up is an appointment with a CSU
icon former German Finance Minister Te'o
Vigo who knows God von from a different
side they have our own frakked soumya he
was outspoken when I was chairman of the
Regional Committee and party chairman
and he didn't put up with anything I
hope that he's the same with others as
he was with me at vons campaign speech
takes place against a backdrop of
traditional Bavarian Oompa music
the oil the euro crisis that we're going
through at the moment is due to the fact
that there hasn't been enough moderation
and that's what I'll bring from Bavaria
to Berlin you could say I'm the bad guy
in the Budget Committee we get a lot of
good advice but we make sure that we
don't spend more than we take in and
that's why I'm asking you to support us
in the election campaign his speech
lasts just a few minutes then he's back
on the bench Alexander fat bun has an
air of modesty about him but it's almost
certain he'll win and within the CSU
he's expected to go on to great things